Oh bartender you forgot my drink it's
okay I can wait oh my gosh I'm such a
Kanye right now give me my damn dream
okay you are at the funny exact like
honestly your turn okay okay if I were
one of the greatest rappers of our
generation which one would I be you are
such a baby how many times a day do I
say it was all a dream oh okay
I'm gonna go out on a limb and you may
disagree with me but I think I am such a
boy I mean I constantly want to pop caps
in people's asses bartender I'm still
waiting
okay guys do me Jimmy okay on the count
of three all together now okay one two
three jay-z what um Justin
we're not jay-z that's you Dre I totally
am a chain Z how dare you call me a
drink
I dropped classics daily at the office
and at home yeah but you're just so
emotional about it I mean still good
what's so emotional um excuse me yeah
excuse me ah excuse me but last week I
gave a presentation that Abe himself
deemed and I quote it's like the
blueprint now how is that not jay-z
honey you included an entire slide show
called how to love yourself better on
YouTube and that is so Drake it sounds
really great
a bartender I'm still waiting for my
drink thank you very much guys what guys
what guys let's not forget that I dated
B hottest chicken aimed at the game
Lorraine from Finance for a year now how
is that not jay-z yeah but when you
broke up you cried for like two whole
business days and then wrote a whole
newsletter about it that is so drinks
okay okay
I'm not break and the fact that you guys
are even calling me trig is hurtful and
I don't know if we can be
anymore no new friends I started from
the bottom and now I'm here you know
what I'm gonna just get my own drink
well just hold on just hold on we're
going home anyway okay yeah we're going
home yeah
could he be any more draining he's the
biggest rate this hesitation I didn't
need to be shot in close it just needs
accepting thank you guys oh my god I am
such a Drake hey bartender it's been 15
minutes how long does it take to make a
Cosmo gosh I am such man right here you
sleep